-Our first guest tonight
is a movie icon,
whose latest
film, "Halloween Ends,"
is in theaters and streaming on
Peacock this Friday.
He's also my weirdo cousin
my mom made me have on the show.
Please welcome Michael Meyers.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ "Halloween" theme playing ]
Why do you have a knife?
Yeah. I can already tell
this was a huge mistake.
Put it down.
Put it down or we're not
gonna do the interview, Michael!
Oh, my God. Unbelievable.
I told your mother --
my Aunt Edith --
I told her you
could come on the show
so long as you
were a normal guest,
and you're already
freaking everyone out.
Is there anything else?
Are you ready to act like
a human being?
Oh, my God, what...
What are you trying to do?
Oh, my God.
Are you trying to trying to
throw to a clip right now?
You're trying to
throw to a clip?
Oh, my God.
Did you bring a clip?
Well, then we can't
throw to a clip
if you don't have
a clip, Michael.
Oh, my God, I swear to you,
ever since we were kids
and I found your
hair collection, I was like,
"There is something --"
Where are you going?
Michael!
Michael! You cannot leave
in the middle of an interview.
This is not "The View," Michael.
Oh, my God, Michael,
where did you get an ax?
Can security please get
the ax from him?
Oh, great.
Really earning your paycheck
today, Jim. Thank you.
Oh, now where did he go?
Oh, my God!
Michael, get
down...from...the...audience!
If you do not, I --
Michael --
will bring out my --
Michael -- next guest.
What do you mean "no"?
Oh, Michael, did you do
something to our next guest?
Oh, my...
Are you kidding me right now?!
Do you have any idea
how hard it's going to be
to book guests when they find
out that you killed one of them?
-Oh, let him have his fun.
[ Laughs ]
-Oh, no. God. Oh, no.
Sexy teens.
Oh, not the night for this.
Sexy teens,
you are, like, his favorite.
You've got to get out of here.
-Oh, don't worry.
We're way too young
and hot to die.
-You guys do not know my cousin.
You either got to
get out of here
or you got to get way less sexy.
-Ooh-hoo-hoo! No can do, Seth.
-I just have a really
bad feeling about this.
Oh, my God!
He's right behind you!
Michael!
Look at me! Michael!
Don't you even think about it!
No!
[ Screaming ]
Michael, you put that neck
right back
where it's supposed to be
this minute.
-Oh, my God!
-Aah! Who could have guessed
this would happen?!
-Michael, if you think
I'm not telling Aunt Edith
everything you did tonight,
you've got another thing coming.
Oh, my God. Get down here.
Oh, my God. Where are you going?
I cannot believe my mom made me
bump Jennifer Lawrence for you.
That's it.
We're done, Michael Meyers.
Ladies and gentlemen, I am so --
Oh, get out of the control room!
Somebody's got to warn Amy,
if there's time, Alex.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'm so sorry.
We'll be right back with
Brendan Gleeson and
Colin Farrell, everybody.